Speaker 1: over the weekend, apparently what
FOX News host Judge Jeanine Pirro believed we
needed more of. Was another xenophobic
anti-immigrant rant on her program,
and so she really did a number on her Saturday
night episode. Here is Janine saying she doesn't
give a damn about why undocumented
immigrants are coming here, that their
reasoning for coming here is merely a distraction.
Speaker 3: I'm after the pandemic and I don't give
a damn what the reason is for their coming here,
and neither should you. It's nothing but a ruse to
prevent you from answering the harder question.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this completely does
away with our ability to say, you know,
somebody who was under 18 and was brought
here by their parents and has committed no crime
is very different than someone who came over as
an adult and maybe did commit some kind of
violent crime. That eliminates the fact that
we are reasonable people who can look at
circumstances and say, actually, it really does
matter what the circumstances of people getting
here were, then the big surprise of the show
is Judge Jeanine Tropp trots out Donald Trump's
daughter in law, Laura Trump, Laura Laura Trump,
who says, hey, you know what, you
people at the border, because, you know,
Biden's not doing a damn thing about it. You
need to get yourself some guns and take matters
into your own hands. What here is the idea?
Speaker 3: It's graceful to see and I don't
know what you tell the people that live at the
southern border. I guess they better arm up and
get guns and be ready and maybe they're going to
have to start taking matters into their own hands.
It should never happen. These people should
never make this dangerous journey here.
Speaker 1: That's an idea, right? I mean, if
the NRA did product placement, it would be
let's get prominent right wingers loved by
the Fox News audience to go on to FOX shows
and talk about how people should buy guns like
this. This is the NRA couldn't buy advertising
this good for their clients who are the gun
manufacturers? We have a country plagued by
mass shooting after mass shooting. After mass
shooting last week, I reported to you we had ten
mass shootings the previous weekend. Most of them
didn't even make major news stories once again
this past weekend. I don't even have data for
yesterday yet. But when I looked on Friday, we had
another four mass shootings in the United States,
a total of four killed and 17 injured at the four
Friday shootings. Then we go to Saturday in the
United States. We had another four mass shootings,
four killed, thirty one injured. Really, the only
one of any of these that made significant news
was the one in Austin, Texas, where 14 people
were injured. As of the last time I checked,
fortunately, nobody was killed. Every day, three
to five mass shootings in the United States,
endless smaller shootings. We're maybe only one
or two people are injured or killed. And Larry
Trump shows up and says, hey, go and get guns
and be ready to use them and take things into
your own hands. When it comes to migrants at the
border who they may be undocumented, they may not
be as if it really even makes a difference when
it comes to suggesting people become some kind of
vigilante force. This is the exact statement that
made in a different context made by somebody else
might be investigated as a possible crime in
many situations. A good rule of thumb to live by.
Here's a here's a little life advice for people
who are seeking it. And apparently many people
are. If you have a situation, you're analyzing
whatever it might be and you start to think,
you know, what might be a good solution here,
introduce more guns into the situation, stop,
stop and really evaluate whether that makes sense,
because in ninety nine point nine, nine percent of
situations where there's a problem, introducing
more guns is not the solution. Almost without
fail, introducing more guns is likely to give you
a worse outcome than a better one. So this is very
dangerous, sickening rhetoric. It is exhausting to
deal with. And it's kind of like a game of whack
a mole. Trump's out of office. But now, Larry
Trump is regularly appearing on TV and saying
the absolute worst reactionary instincts in every
situation, no matter the issue. I got an email
from someone saying, you know, David, that what
she did is really a crime. If you look at 18 US
code, subsection 373 solicitation to commit a
crime of violence, you're not going to get her
on that because if pressed, there's enough
ambiguity where she would say, no, no, no,
no. I just meant people should have guns in case,
you know, undocumented immigrants trespass on your
property or they try to physically attack you or
your children or whatever the case. You're not
going to get her on that. I understand, but you're
not going to get her on that. It's almost as if,
like, they planned their crimes openly and then
they end up not being held accountable. And mostly
that has worked for Trump. And this is not merely
theoretical. Remember, back in when I believe.
This was in twenty nineteen, we had that El Paso
shooting where the suspect said he was targeting
Mexicans, this rhetoric has a real impact. It's
not trivial. It's not merely hypothetical. It's
not merely an academic question. This is rhetoric
that gets people to commit violent acts in real
life. It's horrible. It's disgusting. And sadly,
there's every indication it's going to continue.